this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday august the 10th the joint is
brought to you by and i'm welcoming dish
plate looking for something to cover up
that hole in your wall
this plate is a new metal poster that
you'll want in every room they got
millions of designs available featuring
gaming movies and comics
featuring officially licensed designs
from star wars netflix and many more let
me tell you something they sent me a
bruce lee one holy [__] it's [__]
beautiful it only takes 20 seconds to
hang up a disc blade no power tools no
damages no frustrations once you mount
one you can switch it out and a new
plate and a flash with every one that
you buy
this display plants a tree who's better
than display nobody click the link in
the description to see some of my
favorite displays and save up to 29
get 25 off when you buy one or two and
when you buy three or more
discounts will be automatically applied
to your cart when you click the link or
use code joey j-o-e-y when you visit
this plate dot com again that's
display.com
you're gonna love them
the joint is also brought to you by my
[__] favorite blue chew listen it's
time to get that whistle blown you got
two weeks left in august and you're
still sitting there like a [__] mook
let me tell you something blue chew is
an online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra
sialis but in a chewable tablet all at a
fraction of the cost she's like joey i
don't need nothing i got my dick is
tipped up my goo that's okay
my dick used to be tip top my gootoo but
everybody needs a little help that's
where blue chew comes in it's called
confidence [__] you're gonna walk
in there like you have the biggest dick
in the state
and it's going to be all over with it
just her confidence alone is going to go
i don't want this guy around the process
is simple sign up at bluetooth.com
consult one of them medical providers
and once you're approved you're going to
receive this prescription within days
the best part is it's all done online
you don't have to leave the house you
got to talk to nobody got to go to cvs
and some guy's got to breathe on your
neck bluetooth tablets are made in the
u.s of a
and shipped in a discrete package if you
can benefit from extra confidence when
it's time to perform this is what i'm
talking about blue chewers can help
listen
your whistle's a whistle some days it's
tremendous some days it needs help on
the days it needs help blue chews there
and you're gonna get it for free joey
what are you talking about five hours
for shipping and i'm gonna send you a
month
of [__] bluetooth so you can get the
party started your whistle's gonna
[__] love me you're gonna love me and
the girls are gonna love you or maybe
the boys i don't [__] know who you're
running with these days bluetooth.com
with code joey for your first
month free visit bluetooth.com
for important safety information let's
get this [__] party started it's
wednesday lee syed's in the
[__] house
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
my
what's happening you bad [__]
we're here for another fun-filled
wednesday it's august the 10th
and the uh in-house guest
is my man lisa i'm sorry about that
i didn't bond it off that [__] freeze
pipe before i'm still [__] rattling
in my head it's a beautiful day to be
alive what's up g i'm happy that we've
been having fun the last couple days
that's where that cough came from i
gotta tell you some guys things change
things really change your life they
really [__] do
you know lee's been getting high up in
boston with his girlfriend i've been
getting high down here you know
lee got here sunday we tried to eat some
edibles i think we ate a bag of 300
milligrams
which we could do for [__] breakfast
right five years ago and then
we probably ate a chocolate bar like the
first night no no no we had a drug so we
had
i had like 90-ish milligrams yeah i did
two yeah
oh he gives me no credit he gives me no
credit i ate listen i don't know if you
can call what we were doing and i like
getting high i get high now where it's
like i'm conscious i remember
events
and days
like but yeah and it it does you could
still do with the milligrams though
i could still do my milligrams but they
don't hit me like a mule like they used
to that's why i have to switch them
around
so when i want to switch like at the
weekends i do the abx i want to be heavy
duty you know what i'm saying
but um during the week you don't want to
be [__] killing yourself so i get
true dose from the stoners club with a k
stonersclub.com
with a k they got true dose gummy sour
apples that we had the last couple
nights yeah those are good those are
[__] good guys i gave one to a friend
of mine two years ago like at a 15
milligram he still came at a football
game
not a live game we were watching
football at his house and i [__]
looked at him at one point and he was
shot and i go you know what i ain't
giving no more of these away
because these are [__] people up i
gave you away and they were [__] up so
i had 270 milligrams left and i ate the
whole [__] bag that was a mistake
guys
true dose is [__] strong and they got
chocolates they got kitkat
almond joy you know hershey
twix too i think they got twix
do they taste like it yeah kind of but
they're fun did they do the trick listen
yes
you guys you guys have all seen and
you've made fun of me for how i used to
eat edibles because they tasted like
dirt in la the the gummy squares
are good those are gummy bears
the chocolates
taste as good as an edible as i've
tasted you can always taste a little bit
of the that's why i like the but the
gummies are are great they're small and
you know i used to have to swallow the
stars like pills i would take a chug of
water i would bring water with me in the
car with you because i knew you had
something guys we ate those gummies
i can never eat a star again no like
when they were done they were done
towards the end they tasted so [__]
bad it was like doing a you ever go to a
shitty bar and they have those shots
that the girl brings over
the jello shots that's what they tasted
like they tasted like
jello shots with barbus like not even
like what's a good vodka tito's or
something no they made them with that
[__] seven grain like like three
puerto ricans and me made it when we
were in prison what's that [__] you make
at home it's like oh uh moonshine
moonshine it was [__] terrible i did
not like those stars at the end were
gross then this [__] guy found the
bag in his freezer
and he was still eating them and they
were a year old and they were kind of
like [__] uh
hard like it wasn't like a regular gun
like you knew these [__] had
some stalemates they worked but dog they
were effective the more sales
[__] got
they were like they were like a [__]
uh an expired viking and they hit you
like a [__] mule joke what about like
every once in a while we would clean out
the office and we found because i kept
them in the fridge because they stayed
semi
yeah fresh that's a good way to put it
we love we found some like behind
the speakers behind like in with the um
records that like had gotten dehydrated
like all the water had evaporated
because it was a thousand degrees in
that office most of the time and we
still tried to eat them i feel like oh
yeah at least a couple times i found the
[__] sugar cubes from the acid days
oh
from the liquid acid when we moved out
let me explain something to you guys
i understand i've made a lot of mistakes
in my time
i really [__] have i have made a lot
of mistakes i never want to come across
like i don't make mistakes this is
looking for we got a couple [__]
mistakes lately we made we made we
didn't take the guests when they come in
yeah
that should have been a [__]
automatic put the camera on as soon as
people would have sat down
we would have had [__] for you people
today that you wouldn't have believed
and when we picked up that carpet i
should have sent it to all the church
people because
all you had to do was basically put
water on it like a
a cheeky bear what's those trees that
grow cheer patterns geo pet you get like
a [__] all you had to do with that
carpet was take it home lock the door
don't tell your parents you got it put a
little water in it this thing was gonna
get you high like 10 days because
first you put a little water in it right
put a little water in it and then take
the water out and drink it that's the
first dose
then the second dose would have been to
[__] take that [__] fold it up like a
like a heroin dude does with the
aluminum foil and put like a straw to
that carpet and just inhale what was
coming off that carpet guys there must
have been a pound or two a weed in that
carpet dug in
there had to be i don't know how much
edible dust toenail dust
that one we ripped that carpet up
i remember that at the top like
like it was like a dust thing went up
like we had it was disgusting the couch
we had in there there was so many drugs
in between the [__] seats like that
people would bring and drop
in the [__] seat people have no idea
people really have i was thinking about
something last night when that dude
duplicated the youtube page
and when he took the page away from me
he's like i'm going to release the
hidden camera videos from the church of
you doing coke and we're like
you know
guys let me tell you something that
[__]
the office the scary office
that well you think there was a couple
of those we had this we oh yeah
we had a scary office where i saw the
chick get kidnapped at the 7-eleven at 4
in the morning yeah where the lady
[__] banged on the wall and
said stop smoking dope we weren't even
smoking dope we got that one then we
moved to north hollywood
down the block from the burger place you
know in and out
and that place dog i don't know how we
didn't get today
today in today's california
we would have got mugged there at night
it's only a no-brainer
no-brainer that was not a good
neighborhood at night guys you had no
idea we'd leave there at 1 30 in the
[__] morning there wouldn't be a car
on lancashire
like you see two hookers by the hotel it
was not [__] good that that
neighborhood
where we used to smoke the reefer we
were talking about that the other day
the periscopes how many joints must be
under that [__] stairway
because we used to just throw the weed
when we left there was
and you couldn't get to them like there
was no way you could ever get them
because the stairs are blocking and then
but then on the top of the stairs there
was like a little gate that the owner
must have had a key to or something to
get to do something and that in the end
of the periscope we usually would put
and he would just go over the fence
and no like oh there was a roof yeah
that's right there was a roof there it
was like an edge of a roof so i would
throw the joints over and you could see
like a hundred [__] joints guys
we [__] guys you had we're talking
about last night with the wives his
girlfriend was here my wife was here
and we were trying to explain to them
what the eight years of that podcast was
i was in a [__]
coma guys
when we unwind from that lee had his
three-month adventure in milwaukee which
didn't sound any better than what i was
going through
not really
when he called me he fell asleep on the
kitkats
oh and they were all over his bed and
[__] i'm like lee's not doing well
neither am i i mean i was not doing well
guys i was telling lee last night when
we got here like
i got here august 19th
and
i was a [__] mess like august 21st i
got a minor heart attack in somerset
from the anxiety my heart pounding all
[__] night
and then uh the only way my heart would
stop would be at night when i drank the
tea
and when i would drink the [__] uh
the edibles i would squeeze the edible
out of the capsule and put it in the in
the tea and when then i got so high
because i was just draining like if i
was eating 2 000 milligrams on the
podcast
at this point i was eating 3 000. oh
plus thc pills plus [__] the hashtags
because i had like
100 cases of hashtags when i got here he
gave me everything he had at the store
so i was eating hashtags at night and
one we just moved in here september 1st
august 31st we're sleeping on floors
because we had no furniture yet the
furniture didn't come till september 4th
so the temperature came with uh we were
just down here my wife was living
upstairs i was down here watching i
don't know what the [__] we're doing
and one night i got really [__] high
after the furniture came and this is
when i knew it was time to stop guys
i went upstairs it was like two in the
morning at this time i was going to bed
at four
i'd be out of my mind by two by four i'd
just be a [__] mess drooling the
whole [__] thing
i went upstairs and i was just eating
i was going through one of my edible
[__] you know
sandwiches chicken cutlets i discovered
livoti's
so i had everything from lavoni's the
odd bait shrimp
you know
what's it called yeah i don't know what
you're talking about all day obey i'm
guys i'm [__] eating i got [__] all
over the floor and all and the lights
out
there's just a light in the living room
and the light from outside and all of a
sudden out of nowhere
there's a [__] earthquake in my
living room now
i'm so [__] high i can be strictly
honest with you guys
i did not know it was an earthquake i
thought it was part of the edible
experience it happened sometimes kicking
in i was shot i was shot it's two in the
morning i'm in my [__] upstairs
eating chicken
sandwiches chicken cutlets you know and
all of a sudden this house starts
[__] shaking guys i'm in the kitchen
and this house starts shaking i'm like
okay
that's part of the elbow experience i'm
gonna put this piece of chicken down and
i'm gonna go right to bed
i didn't wake up my wife i didn't say
nothing my wife told the story last
night that she woke up during the
earthquake and started crying because
she thought it was all a dream that we
had moved to new jersey
because why the [__] do you have an
earthquake in new jersey i didn't know
they had them here i didn't know you had
one
the one in freehold the 4.8 6.2
the first week i mean i went to bed and
i was like that's a sign and edibles
will do that to you because sometimes
you'll they go on waves so you'll
already be high and then for a second
edibles don't do that to you the [__] we
were [__] taken does that to you okay
i don't want you to sit at home that's
true this is why i don't need edibles
because he saw an earthquake no nobody
sees an earthquake
when they take 15 milligrams and when
you take 50 milligrams the only thing
you see is a pillow and a bag of wise
potato chips that's the most danger
you're going to get into okay but we
were doing lethal doses yeah that's chc
plus you told me at night we're taking
crap cat tranquilizers i don't even
remember
well
this that's what you claim they were at
the time they were probably not they
were probably not cat tranquilizers but
yeah no all those white ones the little
whites were they white were they they
were the armenian i don't remember what
they were watching for your foot i
didn't give a [__] and those days we
just had to do we were doing that's it
and it wasn't like we were drinking but
we were talking about we never drank
never drank oh with ron white
we'd get drunk though did we i drank a
couple glasses at tequila i was in shock
that's why i recommend ron white tequila
because i was not hungover
and i don't like [__] hangovers
anyway but guys we were in deep
la it was time to pull that [__] show
it wasn't pulled because
it was time we were going to move and
start a [__] new life because
you know sometimes you really think
you're living and you're healthy like
sometimes you walk around and you're
like man i've been doing okay lately
guys i was not healthy it was just a
matter of [__] time before one of us
dropped you know with the road [__] and
him not sleeping and the [__] edibles
and
then it got to the point where people
guests were coming in and bringing in
lethal
you know it got to the point where hosts
were coming in and trying to knock us
out of our [__] game
but we were prepared for them because we
had been at war in the trenches for
[__] eight years the last two or
three years of that podcast before [__]
went off the reservation
and you know uh what's his name [__]
benjamin brad whatever's [__]
benjamin oh and benjamin
i mean you know i'm not proud about owen
benjamin but this was part of what was
going on
you know listen when i left l.a i was
under [__] stress
i was anxious and most importantly i was
[__] tired never just been tired i
wasn't tired from no sleep i was just
tired
i was done with listening to the lingo i
mean
and i always said this the last couple
months of the church i kept saying guys
this pandemic
is gonna change a lot of us
this pandemic is gonna change a lot of
us and it [__] did
everything has changed in our lives
since then
a lot for the better
i think i think a lot of people a lot
for the better but a lot of [__] is
still not right i think
there's still even more mental health
issues in the world in the world like
you know in the united people that you
see
people that you talk to i mean this
really either sped up people's thinking
for me it slowed it down it gave me a
window to look and see what the [__] i
had done for the last 25 [__] years
last time i checked in with myself was
like january 97 and you know when you
land you just go it was like
they pulled me it's like getting shot in
the war that's what happened i felt like
i got shot and they brought me to a
bunker
and i got to feel everything i hadn't
felt i hadn't felt [__] we were all
[__] high we didn't you know
we were always high and we were always
moving part of my anxiety when i got
here was
adjusting to my new life like i i felt
[__] i could feel my skin crawl guys
i didn't know what it was to wake up and
not have to leave the [__] house i
didn't know what that feeling was
anymore i didn't know what it was to get
up at 8 30 in the morning and you
already got three [__] messages
from agents or or an actor or somebody
who wants to use you at 8 30 in the
morning you got to call them back and go
i just woke up guy what the [__] like we
need for you to get the center from rama
city it was just a nightmare guest
yeah podcast you know it was
it was overwhelming guys and you just
get like you get used to it like
your least favorite time of the year at
least when we were in l.a was the
holidays cause like you got used to that
and then there was nothing during the
holidays and like i can't wait
who doesn't like the holidays like you
just got used to like that well gotta
remember one thing guys the holidays in
los angeles
right his dick
his dick
i don't know if those people atheists i
don't know if they believe you know
i don't know what they believe in their
christmas and our christmas are two
different [__] things mm-hmm
and you know thank god for bert kreicher
for inviting me over for christmas with
the kids and my daughter could play with
his daughter and the dogs and other
neighbors that was great but guys
that's where it ended
there was no feast of the seven fishes
nobody was you know here it starts
christmas eve you know you
you do something somebody comes over
then you go to somebody else's house
then somebody else is having something
you don't get home till midnight then
christmas day you stay at home open your
presents jump up and down and at like
three o'clock we were around the corner
already that whole week it was like a
[__]
[Music]
a parade around here like i was in shock
like i wasn't used to it because tell
them about christmas in california
it was me
felicia michaels would come over you'd
have a few you would have more like i
went to your house for i think every
holiday
from
for the most part it was thanksgiving
you'd have people come over and a couple
people would stop by but then they'd all
they have eight million parties they're
going to and it's just uh there was only
one person who went to parties
everybody else stayed put we were
[__] orphans it was me you steve
simone yes steve jerry rocha
felicia michaels
one year we had kate
she had to leave but beside that nobody
really has nowhere to go guys it's not
like it's a joyous [__] event if
you're a producer maybe if people invite
you over hoping you're going to put them
in the movie or something like that but
it sucked
it basically sucked
you know i still remember rogan calling
and going moving to austin and i'm like
no i'm not
and i'm gonna tell you what
it's not because i don't love joe it's
not cause i don't like brian it's not
because i don't like [__] texas how
much we love austin texas papa does it
was because i needed family
it was time to have the people that i
banged it out with
around i love dari i love duncan
i love ryan sickler i love the comedy
store and they're all great and dandy
but we're all men fighting for ourselves
out there it wasn't like we were a team
fighting these [__] it was
every man for himself and as soon as you
had a team you realize they stab you in
the back to get stage time or something
stupid you know it was about stage time
and you're like what the [__] there's
more to life than this guys
so
i don't know it was it was just time to
go the holidays were killing me once i
got the wife and the kid he was like
what kind of holidays it is
what kind of [__] holidays it is
these people don't even say merry
christmas to you on the street
everybody takes off which i don't blame
that was maybe in part that was my
mistake because i was so [__] uh i
wanted to shoot projects like i always
knew that the best part of the year for
me was december
december 1st through december 26 my when
i woke up every morning my dick was hard
because i knew there was a role i knew i
was going to come out that season with
something because all these other
suckers would leave and i go okay watch
these [__] that leave these are
the same people that tell you nothing's
happening to them and i'd say to them
guys stay here now because this how many
[__] things i booked on twitter i
remember i shot a [__] nfl commercial
on christmas eve
gee and yeah and no one else was there
no one else was there and by being that
a guy goes hey
we're going to shoot another commercial
then another commercial we need an actor
for that one stick around for the block
so i shot two nfl commercials
they were shitty commercials because
they were nfl promos and i got 306 for
them so i made 212 uh 306 i made 612 for
the [__] day
but at least i made 612 on easter but i
would sell my christmases
for those stupid roles you know like i
wanted a book [__] i wanted my january
to be busy right and
but even like like you're saying with
your family but for me
i hadn't i would see my mom
twice a year for a week
and me i'm 34 now i didn't think i'd
want to be living with my mom at this
point but it's been a
great
two years to like see her every day and
i told you that didn't i yeah oh yeah
you always said go back with mom
when you're a little lost
when the [__] gets danged you know you
go back to your basement i don't go your
bedrooms now or study i don't give a
[__] mom yeah i'll sleep next to the
water heater i don't give a frenchman's
[__] downstairs just to smell that smell
and it brings you back it brings you for
me i just wanted to i don't know i just
wanted to get back i wanted to get my
life
back to normally that was basically to
[__] it you know
or whatever version of normal well
normal and the normal that i like is
what i'm doing right now this is
the most that i want to do
you know ac dc got a song about whatever
and it's uh
i love the lyrics you know
i know i ain't doing much doing nothing
means a lot to me
i mean look doing nothing means a lot to
me because i have not stopped
since i was 13 12 11 years i've [__]
stopped
i haven't [__] stopped i get up in
the morning and i go outside drink my
coffee for 20 minutes i
i tell the world how grateful i am to be
in the world and [__] and i think about
like what do i got to do it went from me
doing
i'm in my notebooks like my schedules i
would have 10 things in a [__] day
10 things i remember like getting home
and going woof and going [__] i gotta go
back to the comedy store and do three
more shows tonight
now i wake up i got three things on my
books
and you're happy and i'm [__]
ecstatic
i don't have these idiots calling me off
[__] day
trying to put me in clubs and all this
[__] i don't have any of that and i
don't want any of that stuff i'm very
happy with those [__] six shows in
new york i am
you guys you have no idea
you have no idea somebody's been calling
me a dear friend like listen they want
you at this place september 27-28 no i
don't want to do it because that'll be
five shows in september
i only want to do three a month how's
that for you [__]
and just but getting to see mercy too
getting the scene like grow up this is
the most time i've spent with her and
she's almost 10
and she's funny like she's fine like
she's turning into a
like a
perfect mixture of both of you we were
out last night
and we're i was joking with her about
the weather and she goes it was what it
was like that's what they should say at
the end of the newscast what's the
weather it was what it was the day's
over what does it mean and i'm like
you're nine years old
we hang out we're a black couple
that i love to death they're interracial
and they're great people
the dude is black and i love him to
death whenever mercy see them she goes
what's up homie
my heart stops
my heart stop she calls everybody else
by their first name but for some reason
she calls this brother she goes what up
homie and i [__] just shake my head
i'm like oh this is not gonna work out
but
i'm used to it now that was another
thing lee
the the biggest problem i had with l.a
towards the end
was how can i raise my daughter in this
[__] city
yeah how can i raise my daughter in this
city where
you know i love when people judge la and
they've never been there they don't just
know they just don't know and they'll
sit in their [__] newspaper article
at the new york times or the new york
post or whatever the [__] they do
and they sit there because the rules
change when you're in la
the rules change you know the other
night i was watching uh anybody see this
the thing about woodstock the 99 yeah
yeah did we just have that on was that
here yeah we just had that okay
three episodes it's on netflix it's uh
99 i'm gonna tell you what i saw
episode one i saw a lot of naked women
mm-hmm
i saw how people are naked a lot of
naked women first night when i watched
cause the first night we watched two
episodes and then
we watched the third with you oh okay
by the time the first one was open i
looked at my wife and i go i'm surprised
they didn't report a lot more rapes
you know you were thinking with all the
drugs and booze there was and there's so
many by [__] the third episode they
were like after that thing well right
there
right as soon as i told my wife episode
two
um
the red hot chili peppers were on stage
and something that happened i don't even
know if it's a red hot chili pepper
something happened
and a truck had pulled into the middle
of it
like they're on stage and also the truck
just pulls
like you know uh 50 yards away but what
the [__] a truck
and the security ran in there by the
time the security got in there they
opened the truck and there's a guy
putting his pants on
and a 15 year old girl make it uh jesus
so
i was like what'd i tell you terry
and we're getting to this point
the point is once episode three came
they were discussing all the rapes
and all the rapes that occurred and it
was horrible women were getting groped
and tortured they were [__] them in
the corners raping them in the corners
it was not good and they didn't even
tell you everything you know what i'm
saying because they just went up the
board was released they didn't tell you
all this [__] which you have to as a as
an american as a human being you're like
there's more [__] if all this [__]
happened if they built the fire i mean
and it was
and you know again i'm sorry for my
language
but this shit's got to be stopped
it was white people [__]
okay and i'm not talking about the
people who went to the concert you ready
for this one
you got
250 000 people
at a concert this is one of the reasons
i didn't do comedy during the [__]
coven
because this was 99 these kids paid
first off it was 100 degrees and they
took their water when they came in
made them pay for water i mean it was
just a ton of [__] that listen it's
greed but then the white [__] came in
250 000 people
and the guy that organized woodstock in
66 or whatever it was 69
wanted to pass out candles
to what is it a forest fire what are you
gonna do no he wanted to pass out
candles because the head of the
columbine had just happened oh geez and
the head of the columbine society for
kids and again i understand i'm very
compliant i i know what your losses are
but this is 250 [__] thousand savages
and you want to go out there and give
about 250 000 candles
because you want to take a picture for
awareness a youth of gun control
it would be such a great moment no it
wouldn't these guys are animals they
haven't slept in three days they're
[__] filled with [__] drugs
and they smell like [__] they coveted
[__] they were swimming and [__] the new
jerseys bought the new york board went
up there and tested the water these
people shouldn't even have skin by now
within the [__] and the [__] dirt and
what was rome new york you know when you
look at this you know that's not a safe
place for a [__] girl
and that and like that's i think that's
what the difference is though they
wanted the picture with the candles
but with all the money they made from
that festival they could have made a
huge donation
to some organization but no they wanted
they wanted the picture because it would
look good and they don't care they don't
give a [__] so to get them my thing
i noticed that there was a lot of naked
women and i'm like something must have
happened one ally guys
when you go to places like the store
when you go to places like dan tanner's
when you go to any of these places any
and i i would never went to a club in
that life like i don't know what a club
is in l.a but i got to tell you
there's got to be tons of these women in
this club all these women are walking
into these clubs whether you'd like it
and i'm not explaining myself correctly
but they're walking in there naked
without being naked
that's a lot of play but yeah l.a a lot
of places guys they're walking in there
naked even though they're not naked
they're walking in there with their
[__] nostrils wide open
and it's like those young girls that
went to
uh
woodstock
you know they got soul to party
guys it's not a [__] party
it's not a [__] party it's like this
chick that's suing uh
my man there you know beautiful people
we all live and uh marilyn manson when
you're on a date with marilyn manson you
gotta suppose at some part of the date
he's gonna go to put a candle in your
[__] lit okay cause it's marilyn
manson does but you're a girl from like
[__] boulder
you think you want to party with marilyn
manson then when he puts a crowbar up
your [__] you wanna [__] complain i
get it i get it but if you play with
fire you're gonna get burnt ladies this
is something i'm this is something this
is the reason why i pulled my daughter
out of l.a because i couldn't teach my
daughter how to not play with fire and
get burnt when she looked around all
those women were in the game to get
burnt they didn't know they were gonna
get burned but they're gonna get [__]
burnt and you know for all these people
who are sticking up listening you guys
have no idea what goes on in those
disgusting places like l.a
i mean you know everybody talks about
harvey weinstein what about the women
that did sleep with harvey weinstein
i wish before he dies he puts that book
out so you see
you know listen man i'll sleep with him
one time but i'll have a career you
still slept with him you still got a
[__] asterisk next to your [__]
name
you know that's how i put it you're like
[__] anybody who did steroids barry
bonds huh they're the barry bonds yeah
he's like barry bonds of [__] acting
you know you suck i want to know how
many women dick suck harvey weinstein's
dick
okay and even all those women that he
came over and knocked on that door and
raped him
you know
i can't do this [__] we can't do this
[__]
so
there's something to do with power
and out in l.a that makes
that makes everybody kind of sell their
soul that makes everybody in a way walk
around naked
when i got there i walked around naked i
didn't know what to [__] expect and
then as you're there a couple months
you're like you know what this is the
jungle
this ain't no place to walk around
[__] naked these people playing for
keeps
there's a thousand horrible stories that
come out l.a [__] you guys just
don't hear them horrible
horrible for every hundred girls that
come in on that [__] greyhound bus
every day that lay
two thousand of them leave [__] up
from what they've [__] seen
okay what the desperation is how it you
know you i still remember moving to l.a
and again i didn't know what was going
on people said you go to runyon canyon
and you walk
right
so i looked down the block from runyon
canyon i remember i went to running
canyon like three times it's a bunch of
[__] jerk clubs but i still remember
walking into runyon canyon and they had
yogi steve right he used to do yoga on
the side i didn't know him at that time
so sometimes i would pull to the right i
would go to the left just to see what
the people were doing yoga jumping jacks
but i would listen to this table over
here there was eight girls at this table
they would sit there at nine o'clock and
bring their audition sheets
this is how desperate and [__] these
[__] people were
they would bring
their audition paperwork to this [__]
uh
table with these other eight girls they
all had baseball hats on and they would
sit there and talk about how they went
to jack's house
they were talking about jack nicholson
and what jack would make him do
and how great jack was and he's great oh
my god he had blow last night oh
he got it from india from these indians
that had
i would sit there and go these [__]
dude and even then
this is my like my first two weeks in
that lane i would look at these girls
and go
these girls have no clue the animals
that they're dealing with
at that time i figure [__] uh he was
my age jack nicholson 59 57 when i got
that lane maybe these girls were 20. you
know they were all sucking that old
hollywood [__] from easy rider being on
a motorcycle and [__] you know i mean
think about it you need that in your
life these girls are parading themselves
now in some community in idaho
telling people they were actresses
meanwhile they still got the taste in
their mouth from that old nut and jack
nicholson's [__]
you know witness relocation program for
all the people who sucked his dick
i don't i look at l.a now man now i see
right like
when you're there you don't see this and
i've told lee and i've told you guys
when i look at instagram sometimes
and i see these videos of women and
stuff i'm like these people losing their
[__] mind these are millionaires
these people millionaires jumping up and
[__] down
you know if i was a millionaire i
wouldn't be [__] jumping up and down
a goddamn [__] video i'd be at home
counting those 20s there's a big [__]
difference i mean but it's uh
i think that that's how bad the pandemic
has been it's
[__] people up it [__] me up and um
but then again like i when i got back
here i didn't know
doc i was so out of it
it's hard not to be it's hard it's hard
to know
because you like if you watch the news
or you pay attention to what's happening
it seems like everything's
burning the world's gonna end
and then
like you just come back like
i think that's probably why the homeless
problem is the way it is in cat all up
and down california because people like
you said people go there and lose their
mind they and they don't leave they
don't go
the lucky ones go to iowa there's a lot
of them who are just
they had they lost everything i really
felt that was a setup towards the end
also in la i thought l.a towards the end
i seen the homeless population quadruple
and just
a short amount of time something wasn't
right and then they would move around in
200 or a hundred
don't they need a bus
they got nothing but time they just walk
i guess nah something was going on in
l.a like you know
2016 was one thing what about the ones
in vegas though have you seen the
homeless people those are scary bro
vegas san francisco
listen man the [__] west coast is
done
ground zero what's that area they call
in seattle now manifestation area
downtown
oregon guys it's a
i'm very happy
that i'm sitting put
i'm very happy and and you're gonna if
you want to ask me right out i'll tell
you
yes i'm scared
yes i'm scared to get on a plane and go
do four [__] shows
at a comedy club that doesn't give a
[__] whether i want to lose
for the for the sake of nothing you know
i don't i could just life is so
unpredictable now every monday when you
wake up
they [__] throw those shootings down
and it's like these shootings can't
happen like you keep going what
another shooting this weekend in
cincinnati
two weeks ago in chicago so when is the
next one
and it's funny i went to the mall
yesterday i had to go pick up something
the freehold mall and i pulled in and i
saw a cop car
and like i wonder if she's here
arresting
shoplifters or something to happen i
went and i picked up the book i walked
out and i saw the cop call there was
nobody in there
and i'm like oh he's probably here as a
deterrent for shootings at a mall or
something like that yeah
and i'm like wow how [__] up is that
that you're driving by one day
you go holy [__] my kid needs a pair of
sneakers
you pull into the [__] wall you got a
half hour to kill you walk into the
morning also there's a [__] shooter
and maybe you get shot maybe you don't
what does that do to your [__] day
it destroy and that's that's what i
think it is at least because
ella is not all bad no not at all it's
but i think what we what happened is we
got lucky and
we like you're saying you don't want to
like you're scaredish to go on a plane
but you just realized that there's
things you'd rather do
and we were able to like
just change our lives during the
pandemic in that way there's some people
who
because of either losing their job or
the work they just got angrier during
the pandemic
and
like we're just two separate sides i
think you either got
better or you got a lot worse during the
pandemic because like yeah ellie
and la just attracts those kinds of
people that it's just it's a very
selfish because who wants to be a movie
star
very selfish self-centered and i get it
there's a lot of great actors
but it's people who think they're the
best and
like didn't someone just shave their
eyebrow
last week like uh go rapper
yeah she did on instagram on instagram
live and her her publicist was calling
her stop it what are you like and she
was on the phone she's like oh they're
losing their mind i'm shaving my eye
like
that's
that's like that candle thing
their goal
is not to create good content their goal
is not to be good people
their goal is to get as many views as
possible
which can be good
but a lot it l because there's a lot of
good there's a lot of great tv
and move but there's a lot of [__] out
there that's just
like i i want to have you get have you
seen the stuff on like youtube where
people prank like they'll run up to you
and throw [__] at you at a store or
like whisper in your ear no and people
like i think people have gotten killed
haven't they like some youtube
pranksters have gotten killed because
like they throw something
and they think it's hysterical and it's
yeah no we we made the right but and
life is
like all all the fun you get to have
going to like you went to a phillies
game you went to a yankees game
i didn't do this for 30 years no i
didn't do this for 30 years because when
i was in i was in
i enjoy how i feel now about comedy it's
uh it's i'm gonna go down there i'm
gonna give my best whatever happens
happens you know i do some writing
whatever but i'm not working for the
agents i'm not i don't give a [__] with
netflix things i don't give a [__] what
anybody thinks
but to to correct myself
i'm not scared of like uh you know
getting stabbed or something
i'm scared for people i'm scared for me
in general you know i'm scared i'll tell
you what my brother went to chicago this
weekend for comic-con
on the way there there was no problem
the flight great blah blah blah no no no
he got there late and then they bumped
them you know
it's if you know anything about my
brother you give him a million dollars
he won't get there on time so
seriously it's not even funny anymore at
59 it's not even funny though
and uh that night i told him i said
change the flight right now because 6 15
i don't see it no no no i'm different
now
next day i just called at 11. let's see
where he's at i'm just i'm eating
breakfast at [__] uh newark what
happened to 6 15.
[Music]
ugh you're not going to believe it the
uber driver went the wrong way yeah i
don't know i'm surprised you weren't
monitoring the flight to see if it got
already canceled the story you don't
need to get the details
like i told you you just know that
person you know what they're about
they're getting thrown themselves into
this [__] hell let's play the hand
down sit down
don't go nowhere watch him watch what he
does you know he could have changed that
flight for the 10 o'clock he didn't he
challenged himself i believe that's
trick 15. what time did you get that we
got there at 6 20. no you did
but that's the thing not even you know
my daughter has softball right a week
he'll call it three
what time is softball six same field
same field
650 you'll see him with a chair with a
bag what happened joe oh no traffic i
brought ginger up why why did you bring
ginger ale who asked you who told you he
wanted ginger ale like you bringing
ginger ale changed 50 [__] minutes
50 [__] minute i mean he's hysterical
but anyway on the way back last night
again
he called me before he was gonna get on
the plane at 4 30. i'm like
because he can't do it do you know in
1987 he was coming to colorado it took
him three days
he kept eating valium at the airport and
passing on and sleeping during his
flight by the time i got my cuban
sandwiches they had mold on him three
days later oh
i told him i think after the second day
he'd be like oh
he was stuck in pittsburgh i kept
telling him dog don't lose those
sandwiches i'll [__] kill you because
that's all i didn't want to see him i
just want the [__] sandwiches
but uh he this morning i talked to him
and you're ready for this he had a 4 30
flight when he got on the flight he
[__] passed out
he did not know the flight was taken off
at 4 30. he was arriving at newark in
what time did it land in newark
9 30 last night but when he landed when
he landed
they held him on the tarmac from 9 30 to
10 [__] 50.
listen guys the worst i don't mind on
the way in
if i'm going somewhere and you call me
at the airport and the airport says
flight 1154 chicago is cancelled listen
cancel the zany's weekend is not coming
i'm not weird yeah i'm telling you right
now if i book a [__] weekend this is
why i took new york guys this is why i
did this five shows in new york trust me
i'm i'm saving everybody aggravation
because if i were to book miami and i
get to know newark is the number two
most canceled [__] airport in the
country i don't know what number one is
i don't know hell
but
if i get to that [__] airport and it
says delayed and i'm going to miami
right there i called whatever the club
is and go listen
we'll give it a shot in six months
i'm not staying here all day not next
week and i'm not giving him my luggage
that's why i'll keep my weed and
everything on the sleep apnea because if
they said well we can't but you know
what yeah here's the 50. send it to the
house federal express i'm not even
waiting because they if they cancel a
flight it takes you two hours to get
your luggage back
oh that's not gonna mean simone in new
orleans weakening people like we'll send
you a helicopter that's great but we got
no [__] luggage right they didn't
give it to us so i'm not playing that
[__] at all now let me tell you the
other side of that coin let's say i do
make it to miami and i do the [__]
great five shows we had a show on
thursday and i get to that airport six
o'clock in the morning
and it says cancel
what happened on 911 is gonna be a door
prize so what i'm gonna do with that
[__] amp oh i'm gonna pull my hairs
out i'm gonna call every pilot a [__]
sucker the chick at the front desk when
she tells me there's no flight till 11
or they tell you now uh tomorrow at 10
i'll lose it so before that happens
i'll sit here
yeah i'll sit here i'll do uncle
vinnie's i'll do the stress factory and
i'll do [__] uh the sony theater till
february and then we'll see how it looks
in february and february is looking a
little better with the sky then we'll
[__] start taking flights but if not
i'll sit here to my escrows roots i
don't need to go anywhere i really don't
i don't need to go to california i need
to go to your [__] wedding so you
invite me to a wedding listen i wouldn't
go to your wedding if you got married
next door i was gonna say i'm not gonna
you can't blame the pandemic on the
wedding no i'm not going to [__]
nowhere and let all these [__] that
go to these weddings and we're going to
mexico let them get delayed for 12 hours
you get down there you hate the [__]
room and the [__] bride [__] 12
hours to come to your [__] [__]
wedding everybody's got a dress and
white make believe they're having a good
time on the beach you know [__]
weddings with that [__] meanwhile she's
sucking dick at white castle for the
last 10 years in the back of the car now
she's dressed in white and we all got to
be nice oh my god you look so beautiful
you look like a spring bride who gives
you you like a [__] dirty [__] knock
it the [__] off all right
sick and tired of this stupidity going
on
what up dog where's those edibles what
are we doing i'm not inviting you to a
wedding i guess huh i won't invite you
to a wedding i don't know i don't want
to go no [__] weddings guys i don't
have [__] eight hours mike's having
like a two hour wedding that's it
out walk job get the [__] out four hours
he'll be there for two two two i'll
dance one time i won't even say goodbye
no that's the best they'll see the tape
what happened to joey i don't know
there's smoke i used to have to keep an
eye on you because like if we went to a
club you told me like i'll leave you
here i'll let you when i'm ready to go
you better be ready to go so like i
always have to keep an eye on you
don't worry
again when i'm ready to go
i gots to go this is the circle this is
the
you got two minutes from there it's this
is it wrap it up
you know i don't care about listen let's
get together for look
look right here
wrap it up that's conversation sake viva
la vista we'll see you next week and
we'll go i'll leave you
bro my mercy godfather i left her
i left his wife for the judas priest
concert we were 17.
i told that [__] we gots to go and her
little girlfriend she brought was puking
you deal with that i don't give a [__]
i ain't waiting for you
you know i brought you as a favor you
tagged the long [__] uh you know
lay down sally she's puking out a
[__] concert that's not me we'll drop
her off at the red hot chili peppers no
[__] with me dog
i don't give a freshman's [__]
last night my friends went to rage
against the machine real they're doing
concerts still yeah they're doing the
garden all [__] week
four hundred [__] rage against the
[__] machine now i i will say
this though
as much as ever things have changed
you're like somehow you're now the king
people were recognizing we're calling
out to you that you knew like at carvel
last night like people would drive by
just in the area you live in
and like
the entire town knows my friends from
jiu jitsu oh i know a little mexican a
little puerto rican dude which one you
just a little asian dude i saw hit a
left he came over i missed a ds come on
dawg you [__] smell my feet in jiu
jitsu don't call me mister
what the [__] you were saying you farted
in jiu-jitsu the other day oh my god
some guy had me in sight control i was
about to sweep him and right here i had
this knee shield up and then little fart
came out and bank shot off the mat right
into his [__] face oh he couldn't
attack me if he wanted to
that's a good move that's uncle joey's
secret weapon lee i'm happy you're down
here this week i'm happy that uh
you came down you introduced us to your
[__] girlfriend a lot has changed in
leigh's life
and i'm very proud of him he's got a
nice girlfriend you know he's got a
different [__] world mike's about to
get married everybody's getting old guys
i mean you know it's funny how
we're sitting here in front of you today
and you're like come on guys
spark it what the [__] guys
it's not
even
we smoked earlier you know i did a
[__] nice bong hit before
but it's not what it used to be i i just
did a weed inventory a day and i found
two bags of weed in my closet that i
haven't even [__] touched i mean
there's not a lot of weed it's good weed
i gave something to mike today you know
most people don't have an inventory oh
yeah
you have an actual inventory written
down you know you got to know what's
there for the [__]
i got to prepare for the winter oh i
didn't think it was written down you
just have enough to have an inventory i
got it written down i know how many
[__]
abx cbd tablets in that bag i started
with six thousand oh they're down to
like 1800 now and [__]
well you're just every time you eat one
you just write like a little thing on
the like
when i eat i put five i put the check
across go look at that notebook it's ten
pages it looks like [__]
did you do like a date like you should
do like a whole journal like an editable
journal just an edible journal i gotta
see what i'm eating what you ate what
you thought of dog listen guys
you know the sad thing is and people
could laugh and whatever the [__] it is
we weren't getting high in our life we
were way past that
the edible count
and everything else count in la was
non-existent
i could sit here and tell you guys
what did we smoke last night
i did two bong hits she smoked a joint
yeah i did two freeze pipes maybe three
freeze pipes that's it guys
i don't need
anything i've been threatening to take
out the big freeze pipe the bong the
king of the bunks who are you
threatening you because i want you to my
dream is for lee to be doing a bong hit
and i just flies out that's no that's
going to happen you have to pick take
the eye put in the baggie drive him to
the hospital and then he'll give him the
honorary [__] high patch he'll be
walking around with an eye patch his jew
is a jew his eyeball of being a little
glass or whatever if you're looking good
if he needs to look into your [__]
then he'll put high end
to focus if he needs to look at your
[__] make sure you haven't got it run
over by a [__] hot wheel you know oh
but you were talking like about hash
earlier
like we smoke ways that haven't been
around in 20 years like the hash under a
glass that we used to do we're getting
[__] up that actually we used oh and
people were trying to do it but the hash
would melt and they would go what the
[__] cuz you got that shitty hash we had
the one-eyed jew direct from israel that
[__] was the [__] they gave to [__]
the palestinians when they captured
dog the wheat i smoked today that's the
[__] that alex jones smoked when he got
the tab that 48 million dollars he got
that they just gave him a joint of this
he took a hit of that he gave it back
and they looked at the tab again
bring it back
bring it back a little bit a lot of
[__] zeros guys
but i wanted to fill a lot of people in
what happened in l.a it was uh
here i could tell you what the [__] i
eat in l.a i can't even tell you
you couldn't
i was thinking about the day with the
banana bread which one
well
it was one of my worst days because i
didn't play it like i i should have you
know
and that's that's just to let you guys
know i used to go to this one [__]
weed store and they had banana bread
it was russians these [__] gave
out bagels at 7 30 in the morning and
they would have city workers in front of
it it was
you could only write this [__] nobody
ever busted them nobody ever pulled over
i don't know if he had a license or not
or whatever but he did have some cool
people working in there
and i would go in there
and he would go joey three customers
came in today and two of them bought
your banana bread
bunny for you yeah i would he would tell
me after the fact
like after i went up there and dropped
my 200 then he would go joey by the way
somebody and i go
why'd you let me buy these four
if i already got [__] two you know
like that's the way our life was there
was a p when we first started rolling
like by 2014 13 12
everywhere we were going there was a bag
of weed for us
okay and wherever we went whoever gave
us a bag of weed we didn't want to let
their feelings down so we did whatever
we had to right there
i still remember auntie dolores in san
jose oh yeah when i ate the 500
milligram brownie and i almost had i
almost died they had to bring me a
chicken sandwich because i was about to
go on stage
and just everything took over me and i'm
like why would i eat that i'm like bro
when you're on war you gotta have that
uniform on you i'm saying we were at war
i i used to go to open mics high because
i'm like joey's going to have me go on
stage high
so i have i have to be i have to be and
and that's the thing because here's
here's the card that i will give you we
can i can't do
anywhere near the milligrams i used to
be able to do nothing either but i could
handle it like i'm just i'm so used to
like the feeling of being high like i
don't think i would ever freak out
or like
i might fall asleep
but i'm not gonna like freak out or like
lose it or call an ambulance like i i'm
like okay i know what this feels like
well before it was over the top i mean
come on guys who eats mushrooms 2 000
edibles and a half a hit of acid
that's we did you know
that's that's that's one week of
episodes that was the one week with dean
delray when you got sick that night yeah
that wasn't necessary i felt horrible
that night i felt horrible because that
wasn't necessary the poor kid was asking
me are we in the hospital
because in the office he kept asking me
are we in the hospital he would talk to
me he would look at the lights and go
we're in the hospital and i'm like
there were blinds that reflected onto
the tv screen so it would come in and
out of consciousness and it looked like
i was looking out of like a window in a
room
and i was like oh my god i have i hope
i'm not
oh yep we had fun though
dawg
we had nights we had guests that were
tremendous we had
people that were tremendous we saw lee
got to see some [__] that
you know from actors popular actors
well-known actors lee got to see some
[__] that was like
you know and it was an education it
really was an education for lee and it
was definitely a [__] education for
me and and i got to tell you man
i think me and mike had these
conversations when we started doing the
podcast and i told mike specifically
and he didn't understand why i'm like i
don't want to go there again
i don't even want to go to that podcast
again
it was great you know those things that
when you do that great while it happened
i mean if you sit down slash and
and uh axel
and talk about you know the three years
they were on the road
it sucked
i bet it sucked i bet they had a
you know a lot of mine and it didn't
suck you know they got their dick sucked
they got hammered they did drugs they
made money i mean that's what it means
that sounds a road that's what it means
to go on the road but when they went
home that day
when they got on the plane they looked
at each other and go and they don't talk
for a year after you've been together
for three years you know zz top all
those bands at one point went out for so
long that when you land you're like see
ya you know we're not talking at all
don't call don't write tell the manager
when you're ready to write a lyric to
other manager calling you're like listen
i ain't ever writing a [__] lyric
again so it's like but when you look all
those guys i would love to interview
jimmy page about the 77 tour now
not in 78 where his perspective was a
lot different
now now i could look at my comedy what i
did in lango wow it was fun it was scary
i'll do it again but do i wanna no i
don't wanna go to that place again that
80 the [__]
you know the 90s were great the earl
2000s but i got to live like this weird
like i went from just an open mic comic
to a like a comedy store comic
just in limbo for five or six years when
i realized what i really wanted to do
and then i locked in so it was a long
[__] time
a lot of thinking you know and it wasn't
thinking a lot of planning guys
and it gets old
it gets old after a while and i look at
these guys and i came up with bert joe
all these guys they're they're still out
there making it happen but they're not
59.
they're not 59.
bert's getting close you know tom's
getting close
joe's up there i think joe's birthday is
uh maybe this week or next week i don't
[__] know he turns whatever 55 or
something but
it was when i was about 58 57
it was when i started to feel it and i
wouldn't have felt it guys
if i didn't have a family
if i didn't have a family it wouldn't
have mattered
i would have been dead by now from the
road like i told terry if we wouldn't
have mercy
she would still have a great job and i
wouldn't have came back on tuesdays on
mondays
i would come back and do four podcasts
and then leave for two weeks what am i
coming back for
right i don't have to take it to swim
meets or anything like that so
i want people to understand that that's
part of the whole thing you know mercy
was the one that was like that i don't
like this no more
it's not fun anymore you know it's fun
but not really i don't like uganda that
much
and that weekend with bert when i got
back that was the end
that was the end well even just her
coming down to watch tv with us last
night
if you were gone she can't do that if
you like even if you were at the store
you would have been gone
listen i missed the daughters growing up
already it was a daughter's life that
went by and i didn't see it i was not
gonna do it again and not to stand up
you're right you know not to stand up
not that i already did everything i
wanted to do
so what would i stand out three four
more years five more years so i did an
arena
and then what start from scratch
i was ready to move on man to take my
life in a different direction help other
people maybe i don't know i don't know
sell some weed i don't [__] know but
that's you know that's what life is
about and i have accepted it you know i
told my wife today i'm i'm comfortable
in my skin again
i'm very very comfortable in my skin i
know what my mission is
i got no mission it's like that
uh commercial with snoop dogg and the
guy from
uh 22 whatever that show was on that i
did
20 24 no
what's that he has a commercial with
that young kid
now and the kid goes from slow snoop
what are we going to do and he goes
no plans is the best plan and the guy's
checking his phone yeah and he throws
his phone into the bucket oh i missed
that one yeah i did that show what's his
[__] show on fox with the kid from
signing out live adam
sandberg and that [__] hook face
they went over there brooklyn nine-nine
brooklyn nine-nine now you're [__]
it's like it's like the joey diaz trivia
game yeah the [__] weird the chick
that contributed to the joe diaz is a
bad guy campaign and then [__] took
off the campaign hook face well she
[__] uh
she's in that show too
but no i'm happy life changed i'm happy
we're here i'm happy we could still do a
podcast with brothers in arms
you know uh that's it [__] it's
a beautiful [__] wednesday
it's laid back and this is us
two years [__] later almost
we have we stopped the podcast two
[__] years ago like in july august it
was august we left it because we left
august 19th so
two weeks before that so it might have
been like today yeah it might have been
like what day is today
to the tenth yeah and if you look at our
last podcast was it paulie
well yeah it was polly but we we went
and recorded it and then put up paulie
from a couple years before who was the
real last podcast it might have been sam
was it sam that was a good [__]
podcast when he showed us the cannon
with the lysol cannon that had
coronavirus in it oh jesus yeah and then
the new ones that came out didn't have
coronavirus in it he's like i told you
something's not going on [__] sam
that's one dude i missed abx set me up
last week
and they go are you coming back to l
anytime soon i go nah and they go cause
sam's doing comedy chaos and we're the
sponsors again so i was like man that
would be fun go on a tuesday [__] do
the early show that was a fun night that
was a [__] fun night
and listen guys listen
if we all went back to the store
one of those tuesday nights it would be
great
but at the end of the night we would all
walk away and go
that was different right now i want
those memories just to sit in my mind
right the store the church
i want those memories just to sit in my
mind it's like i told my wife and your
girlfriend last night that
things happen sometimes
nothing is worse than somebody going
we're going to reboot something
and then you see it and you know
first of all we rebooted the church
everybody would hate us
because it's not the same
we're not the same people we think
differently
we don't have the same people around us
i mean you know
uh and just it just wouldn't work we
both evolved from that mike's evolved
i've evolved i mean i can't
i don't know what to [__] say i
wouldn't know what to do you know
it all happened naturally we never like
and there's no this is no hate to any
other podcast but some podcasts try to
have like the fun that we had
and some of it feels like oh this is the
podcast we didn't always take it we took
him a lot but like we we took edibles
just because like it wasn't it wasn't
like the show wasn't an edible show it
was like we were taking edibles and
having fun
it wasn't like we were going back and
forth
like oh let's take edibles let's be
crazy
no it wasn't like that at all because to
be honest with the people
we've been doing edibles every day
i mean we're talking about the rides we
took and how we made it to these places
you know we went to harrah's in san
diego i couldn't even [__] see i was
so hot all i could see were lights and
[__] in front of me you know we went to
we used to go to irvine the night before
thanksgiving that was always
a 200 300 milligram two eighths of weed
down there we just throw it on the table
i still remember getting yoshi high on
the [__] banana bread oh that's a
great one you know i have not heard from
him since he's never spoken to me again
for yoshi we took him back to japan he
was flying through the [__] air with
swords and [__]
i'm happy you came down lee i love you
more than welcome always to come down
and hang out and have a good time with
us and hey we're here we're still making
it happen regardless of what the [__]
going on don't forget
to go to amazon order
tremendous tremendous story of a comedy
savage it's still pre-order
uh and that's it that's all i got going
on tickets are sold out in new york do
not buy a ticket over forty dollars do
not buy or take it over forty dollars do
not buy or take it over forty dollars
don't be so stupid that four hundred
dollars save your money you don't need
to see joey joey will add more shows
later we are not making ticketron rich
we are not making chickatron rich we're
doing a [__] pro jam all over again
[__] tickatron charging foreign for
working class people that i put those
tickets at 40 [__] dollars i hope you
guys know that forty dollars that was
perfect two years that's 80 20 for the
baby said that hopefully she's missing a
hand she can't chase the kids you know
it costs like 50 for a [__]
babysitter but anyway okay you know what
i'm saying half price for one hand do
not
[__] pay over 40 dollars for those
tickets i'll be back
i'll be back trust me what i'm telling
you
have a great weekend
thank you thank you thank you mike and
now thank you mike for a word my
[__] sponsors jack
all right i want to thank you guys for
the support i want to thank lisa for
coming in today
but i gotta thank you [__]
because you're the the goods that's how
i look at it anyway i got a little
something for you today
the joint is brought to you by blue chew
listen complex should take you far in
life
it could also help you in the bedroom
that's where blue chew comes in you're
like joey what's blue chew it's an
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
at a fraction of a cost you know how
much they want for viagra when i go to
the doctor 80 a pill [__] them
[__] that that's why i popped up with
blue chew they're tremendous the process
is simple you sign up at bluetooth.com
you consult one of the local medical
providers and once you're approved you
prescrip you'll receive your
prescription within days
the best part of it it's all done online
no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations no nothing
bluetooth tablets are made in usa and
shipped in a discrete back is the
mailman no no dick if you can benefit
from extra confidence when it's time to
perform
bluetooth is definitely going to help
you try blue chew for free joey come
free
use promo code joey and just pay five
dollars for shipping bluetooth.com code
joey for your first month for free do me
a favor visit bluetooth.com for more
information and safety information i
don't want you taking eight of them you
got a heart out for two months nobody
needs that [__] in their life the joint
is also brought to you by display listen
this plate is a cool new metal poster
you'll want in every room they look
tremendous they're shiny they sent me a
bruce lee one yellow with the suit from
the game of death [__] tremendous
they got millions of designs available
with gaming movies and comics and they
got licensed designs from star wars
netflix and a lot of other people takes
only 20 seconds to hang a display no
power tools no damages no frustrations
once you mount one
boom you can switch it out and a new
plate and a flash
click the link below
for some of my favorite displays you
could see some of my favorite display
and i'm going to save you 29
you get 25 off when you buy one or two
and 29 off when you buy three or more
and remember with every display that you
buy
they plant a tree that's how strong this
plate is who's better than them nobody
discounts will automatically be applied
to your cart when you click the link or
use code joey j-o-e-y when you visit
thisplate.com again that's display.com
code joey i want to thank this plate i
want to thank [__] bluechu i want to
thank
who else we gotta thank you oh
betterhelp.com got deck of your mind and
i want to thank true classic t-shirts
they're [__] tremendous i got i had
one on today you see how nice it [__]
looks i love you [__] say goodbye
lee goodbye everyone thank you for
listening and watching can you believe
this [__] guy stay black i'll see you
monday morning
[Music]
it's your phone
you